today's video is sponsored by surf shark
adele
wins a brit award and her comments
become new she really wasn't expecting
this one at all like
yeah and also i would say you know i
understand why the name of this award
has changed but i really love being a
woman and being a female artist i do
i do
i'm really proud of us i really really
am thank you so much
okay so that was the comments
that started the whole thing and then uh
you know the reaction to some folks got
upset
one person said who'da thought that
adele was a transphobe who would use her
platform to call for the destruction of
the trans community especially the
confused teenagers someone else said
please know adele can't be a turf
the last
comment though
ambiguous could be perceived as turfy
please no okay
now when people send me this story you
know i'm like all right what's this brit
award and it turns out he used to have a
female in a male category they decided
to make it just gender neutral like all
uh award shows adele she came on she
said listen i love being a female and i
love that and i want that to be
highlighted as part of my journey being
proud
to be who you are without infringing
nobody she's not
saying anything she said i'm proud to be
a woman
she's not commenting when she said oh
yeah it's just and she's infringing all
of this and then just yo she's she said
that she didn't say that it makes me
think of remember that reporter that was
with jordan peterson
so what you're saying is also what
you're saying is
it feels like that's what it is
i personally don't have a problem if one
who wants to be proud to be a woman just
make sure you're also proud on your
period you feel me don't be out here
cursing your [ __ ] gender and your sex
and be like oh if i gotta bleed be proud
then too yeah but i don't think that was
a point that was and i don't i don't
think that was the case
what that she's not proud of of being a
woman when she has a period whatever i
mean i know a lot of women aren't i mean
feminists in the streets yeah that's
that once it gets a little bloody bloody
of course they're like hey that's them
why i know that's them
for that reason you're proud to be a man
i understand that what when they have
their period oh yeah i'm the most proud
when it's my girl's period yeah she
starts to bleed i'm like damn man hey
mel stand up
we out here consistent mood [ __ ] so are
you sane yeah that's what i'm saying
whatever you think i'm saying is what i
said [ __ ] when it's her period i feel
the most amount of pride yay
oh undoubtedly i'm mad at you yeah and
when i get [ __ ] testicular cancer
that's her moment to be proud to be a
female
of course when you get kicked involved
yeah that's you yeah that's all you yeah
when she's tickling my balls i'm like
that's her moment to be proud
right we all got her sensitive spots i
only know i'm proud to be a male when i
see her struggle
you get what i'm saying you get what i'm
saying yeah but abba there's a
difference between being proud and being
happy you're being happy you're being
male being proud is just
i'm i'm happy april i'm sorry
cute pharrell and i'm happy i don't give
a [ __ ] when i see your friends
some girls are struggling on their
period so absolutely you know yeah yeah
so shout out to the men video is brought
to you by surfsharkvpn a vpn is an
application or an extension that you put
on top of your browser in order to
change or to mask your ip address you
know to change the location of your
computer why would you want to do that
well sometimes i want to listen to other
content from other country and they
won't let me in knock knock who's there
canada won't let you in unless you're
from the uk
switch the vpn changer and then boom
knock knock who's there
it's actually the uk now
yes come in lord come have some fee i
know you guys don't speak like that but
you know what i mean so you're able to
watch much more content and then boom
the world is open to you just like
aladdin on a carpet i can show you the
world and then for the next month you
have 83
off and the three next month's three if
you use abba and preach code a
surfsharkvpn use the link below go ahead
so i'll i'll say this i think it's
twofold one i think a bit of this is
probably manufactured i think sometimes
twitter i just i don't take the opinions
i see on twitter very seriously it's
like being representative of anything
real all right that's me personally i
just when people see me like look at
these people overreact on twitter like
is this even real
some people like already you're a giant
loser for being on twitter if you're
watching on twitter you're a loser too
okay i'm serious i'm just gonna say it
it's a it's it's a shitty platform it's
it's it's absolutely the worst dog [ __ ]
takes you could ever find it's not yeah
it's what i mean you mean a platform
where you're gonna yeah you have 140
characters to express yourself
and be the most outraged french okay one
two
knowing that it's some of it's
manufactured there's also a portion of
the people who really think like this
but how important is it really me i
start to take notice when i hear
politicians absorb this rhetoric and
sometimes you start to see some overlap
because i'm sure
if you went up to somebody who's like a
head organizer of the brit awards and
you'll be like excuse me sir
do you feel like what adele said was
transphobic when she was up there
there's probably some people who start
sweating and i think this is the
insidious part i don't think it's the
people on twitter it's how some people
believe this [ __ ] is so real it starts
to affect your worldview absolutely
right even though i think some of the
people who may have initially started
may have been fake trolls or whatever
there's really people out there there's
like that does kind of sound turfy
that that's what's crazy there's some
people that that their brain is not in
their brain is not in their head right
their brain is actually
chinchilla no that's not feather
lint looks like um yeah um
that's how you know it's still pouring
my head i saw a lint i'm like that must
be chinchilla it might be it's possible
yeah yeah yeah well maybe not okay um
yeah their brain is not there their
brain is on twitter they go on twitter
and they're like
that's my take and then they leave they
don't think about it they don't need to
think someone already has
regurgitated all that they need to be
able to chew it uh they've been able to
digest it regurgitate it i'm gonna take
all of that without thinking if it's
right or wrong if it's dude or whatever
what not let me just
i i don't even think it's that you don't
think is that i think that people are
terrified of being quote unquote
cancelled and i say canceled in the
sense that there's a huge mob of people
who start criticizing you and peering
into your life people are terrified of
coming under that kind of scrutiny right
so they start to look what they see
online like oh you can't say that yeah
and it starts to affect them internally
right i think the most insidious aspect
of cancer culture is not the idea that
people are going to be removed from
society or people can be heavily
scrutinized or criticized for things
that may be undeserving i think it's how
it affects everybody else who's watching
who starts to watch what they say the
words that they use the way that they
engage in a conversation or choose not
to because it appears like there's so
much red tape about it right so i think
that's what's really telling about this
story because i do feel like somebody's
just like no you're trolling like that
the first twitter tweet i'm like no i
think you're true you're not serious but
i do really believe that some people
would not be comfortable saying what she
said because they think it's turfy which
is trans exclusionary that's what i
think is [ __ ] up but that's just it
might be that it's possible yeah it's
possible yeah but
yeah it's just weird yeah that's the the
so what you're saying is that that whole
thing yeah that's cringe to me it's just
wack
no that's not what i said i was right in
front of you when i said it you heard
what i said play it back play back i
didn't include none of those things or
those words that you said play back it's
right there play back bring it back play
it i've said none of those things
but yeah it is what it is and that's
where we live in what do you think
like
she said she was proud to be a woman
saying that you're proud to be a woman
is now you're denying
that you're denying the life of trans
people and you're denying that oh my god
i can understand how you seem like that
yeah because she's privileged
she's white cis a woman the sister white
cis woman god damn
it's all about trans oh you're
privileged
so you can no longer talk but she can't
because she can't you can't talk about
that [ __ ] without [ __ ] up the whole
thing but i i think it's
crazy but on your other end i'm like you
know what are we at the point where it's
really complicated for women to to is it
i'm just asking the question i don't
know i'm not a singer is it more
complicated for a woman to men is it is
that this point
or you're a singer you're a singer i
don't know
is it more complicated for trans people
to be out there
i don't know who cares
also
who cares probably probably won't be
probably a woman i'll be proud to be a
white black whatever i don't give a [ __ ]
go do it who cares tell us what you guys
think in the comments below we want to
hear from you right now